that's a bit controversial i think i
think what i would say in general terms
though is that if i think about it not
as like not as a chess player but just
as a fan i mean uh you you want you want
to see the games if if maxine shows up
in a tank top and and uh and flip-flops
i don't really care exactly because i
want to see it see his games at night
over burnfield so i don't i don't think
it's it's such a big deal i mean there
should be some professionalism but i
think at times maybe it's too much but
okay that's that's for others to decide
are you comfortable comfortable playing
in a suit
um yeah i mean i have to say that it's
it's kind of weird for me because i
didn't wear a suit for two years and
probably the last few years uh
i mean i wore shorts and actually like
sandals most of the time so
uh it's it's a little bit different but
i mean it's not it's not like something
i haven't done before just sort of you
kind of get back into it you get used to
it and um
and so yeah it's just something you do
it a lot i mean you might forget for a
while but you never completely forgot
thank you